Dangle:
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT!
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
HEY, HOW Y'ALL DOING?
THERE HE IS.
THIS IS PRIVATE
PROPERTY, SIR.
IT CERTAINLY IS.
PRIVATE PROPERTY.
NOT YOUR PROPERTY,
SIR.
MRS. HENDERSON CALLED.
SHE SAID THERE'S A BLACK MAN
DRESSED UP LIKE A COW
ON CRACK COCAINE
HARASSING THE GOATS.
OK, SHE DID?
SHE DID?
YEAH, SHE DID.
THAT GOAT WAS
HARASSING ME.
REALLY?
EXCUSE ME.
THAT GOAT WAS
HARASSING ME!
WHAT DID THE GOAT
SAY TO YOU?
HE SAID, HEY, MAN,
WHY YOU UP IN THIS PEN
WITH PEN WITH YOUR--
I KNOW YOU AIN'T A COW.
I SAID I DIDN'T SAY
I WAS A COW.
YOUR STORY
DOESN'T CHECK OUT.
THIS STORY DOESN'T
CHECK OUT.
WHAT DID SHE SAY?
TELL ME WHAT SHE SAID, THEN.
BLACK MAN, COW COSTUME,
CRACK COCAINE,
SHE SAID--
HARASSING MY GOATS,
TRESPASSING ON MY PROPERTY.
OK, YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET'S REFUTE THOSE
ONE BY ONE.
OK, I'M GONNA REFUTE 'EM
CRACK HEAD.
I CAN'T REFUTE
THAT ONE, OK.
DRESS UP LIKE A COW.
WELL, I'M O FOR 2, THEN,
FINE.
HARASSING MY GOATS.
THAT I DIDN'T DO
'CAUSE I WAS UP IN HERE.
WE'RE WATCHING
YOU RIGHT NOW!
WE SAW YOU DO IT!
I SAW YOU DO IT!
I WASN'T HARASSING THEM,
MAN!
I WAS OVER HERE.
THIS M--THIS LITTLE--
DON'T POINT AT HIM.
AH!
SON OF OF BITCH.
GODDAMN IT!
STOP!
FREEZE!
GODDAMN IT.
CRACK MAKES 'EM FAST.
HE'S HEADING STRAIGHT TO--
STRAIGHT TO MOUNTAIN
LION COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY'LL TAKE CARE OF HIM.
MOUNTAINS LIONS
WILL GET HIM.
IT'S THE CIRCLE OF LIFE.